merci la parole est à monsieur philippe
meunier merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
gouverner c'est prévoir après cette
série d'attentats perpétrés par des
islamistes dont certains ont la
nationalité française
la colère gronde dans nos villes et nos
campagnes
nos compatriotes ne supporte plus et
avec raison de voir leur identité de
francs s'est ainsi dégradé et bafoué le
4 décembre 2014
votre majorité a balayées d'un revers de
main notre proposition de loi visant à
déchoir de la nationalité française les
islamistes binationaux proposition qui
n'a pas besoin d'une révision
constitutionnelle le 2 avril dernier
après les attentats de janvier nous
avons re déposer une seconde fois ses
propositions de loi que vous avez un
nouveau écarté sous prétexte que la
législation actuelle était suffisante
puis hier le président hollande a
reconnu que la législation ne répond pas
à nos besoins de sécurité ce qui revient
de facto à soutenir notre proposition au
mot près
que de temps perdu que de temps perdu
mais si déchoir de la nationalité
française les islamistes est une
nécessité absolue pour expulser du
territoire ces traîtres à la nation il
est tout aussi important d'accorder la
nationalité française avec parcimonie
or depuis l'élection de françois
hollande le nombre de nanette ne te
naturalisation augmente sans cesse
la semaine dernière vous avez décidé
d'attribuer plus largement encore la
qualité de français aux étrangers
déclarant même vouloir en doubler le
nombre
outre le caractère symboliquement fort
de cette acquisition
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir qu accorder
la nationalité française à un étranger
lui donne des droits conséquents
notamment en termes de liberté de
circulation et de résidence sur notre
territoire
ma question est donc direct allez vous
sans plus attendre voir votre politique
afin de rendre plus restrictives les
conditions permettant d'obtenir la
nationalité française
merci la parole et à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député meunier
l'action contre le terrorisme contre le
terrorisme de guerre se mène sur tous
les fronts je le rappelais il n'y a pas
une mesure en particulière personne
d'ailleurs ne le dit qui permettrait de
régler le problème qui se mène d'abord
je veux leur rappeler jean yves le drian
est l'occasion de le souligner sur le
terrain extérieur et en frappant des
shsh l'état islamique en irak comme en
syrie c'est ce que nous faisons en irak
lé déjà depuis 2014 c'est ce que nous
faisons depuis plusieurs jours en syrie
y est je le disais tout à l'heure les
événements terribles que nous avons
connus permettent aujourd'hui de faire
bouger les lignes et un certain nombre
de pays et de créer nous l'espérons
cette grande coalition contre le
terrorisme et je veux de ce point de vue
là ici également salué l'engagement de
nos pilotes dans sur les rafales sur les
mirages et qui désormais tous les soirs
toutes les nuits accomplisse ses
opérations semaines sur le front
intérieur bien évidemment qui peut
l'ignorer et ce sont les moyens que nous
allons donner à la police à la
gendarmerie aux services de
renseignements aux services de justice
aux douanes ses moyens en termes
d'hommes de femmes de postes que nous
n'avons cessé d'augmenter depuis 2012 et
nous allons poursuivre mais ce sont
également des investissements importants
dans les budgets de fonctionnement ont
baissé entre 2007 et 2012 et dont la
police et la gendarmerie ont besoin
parce que pour faire face à ce
terrorisme lancieux et elles ont besoin
de moyens
et puis ce sont les choix qui ont été
évoqués hier par le président de la
république en ce qui concerne notamment
la révision constitutionnelle pour
intégrer un certain nombre d'aspects de
la loi de 1955 et de celle révisée que
nous présenterons demain en conseil des
ministres mais aussi présents la
république le rappelait aussi concerne
la déchéance de la nationalité
apporter une réponse
juridique efficace le ministre de
l'intérieur le soulignait au défi du
terrorisme
c'est donc élargir la possibilité de
déchéance de nationalité
le code civil le code civil permet de
déchoir de sa nationalité
une personne ayant acquis la nationalité
française ayant été condamné pour
terrorisme
sauf si cela a pour effet de le rendre
apatride
la révision constitutionnelle proposée
permettra de déchoir également de
nationalité une personne née française
disposant de la double nationalité est
condamné pour des faits de terrorisme
pour atteinte aux intérêts fondamentaux
de la nation je vous réponds donc très
précisément enfin monsieur le député
pour conclure dans ce débat avec la
colère les angoisses les peurs de nos
concitoyens je pense sincèrement que
nous avons une responsabilité c'est de
faire en sorte que l'unité de la nation
soient préservés chacun pas uniquement
l'unité de la représentation nationale
pas uniquement de ceux qui représentent
la nation mais de la nation et la
confusion que vous opérez dans votre
question le fait de rendre par les
propos que vous tenez tout étranger
suspect ça vous nous trouverez toujours
devant
pour dire non non précisément je veux
rappeler que sur les trottoirs de paris
monsieur le député et dans la salle du
bataclan il vous plait il ya eu des
étrangers qui ont été tués il ya eu des
français d'origine étrangère
il ya eu peut-être même monsieur le
député et français qui avaient acquis
leur nationalité
et parce que moi par mille autres je
fais partie de ceux qui ont décidé un
jour de devenir français parce que
j'aime ce pays
par dessus tout je le permettrais jamais
cet amalgame
cet amalgame qui met en cause les
valeurs de notre pays
merci les filles
allez je vous demande devant la sorte
s'il vous plaît